every day Air Canada takes on the
impossible synchronizing the chaos of
air travel when it works it's a symphony
in the sky an unseen conductor timing
the
takeoffs and landings of 1,00 daily
flights in such a way that 140,000
passengers get to where they want to be
unhindered by delays or lost
bags
[Music]
if only it were that
easy the truth is frustrations are
common so in terms of complexity of
getting our passengers safely to where
they want to be on time a lot of things
have to go right there are literally 60
things which need to go right for an an
aircraft to land on time only 30 of
those do we actually control as an
airline Bruce Stam leads the artificial
intelligence team at Air Canada since
2020 they've been working to integrate
AI to minimize the potential for
mistakes the goal is to save time in
late October Bruce's team started using
an AI assistant to optimize its
scheduling and predict delays
we look at the schedule 3 to 5 years in
advance it may not look like much but it
churns through massive amounts of data
even a 10-minute delay at the beginning
of the day can cause a ripple effect Ai
and data are going to be part of our DNA
just to do a lot more effective decision
making and next year they plan on using
AI to overhaul the maintenance schedule
for their 200 planes what takes weeks to
do will soon be done in 15
minutes AI is here whether we like it or
not so what we're doing at Air Canada is
embracing this leveraging this to the
better of our employees experience and
ultimately our passengers experience and
it's also
FL this may surprise you but Canada's AI
pioneering dates back to the 1970s when
researchers formed the world's first
national AI Association and this is a
good time to distinguish one AI from
another let's start with deep learning
AI found in the software of autonomous
cars facial recognition and mass
surveillance this is the AI that has the
potential to think for itself and that
scares a lot of people then there's the
field where Canada is considered a
leader machine learning AI which most
people don't realize we already use
every day it curates social media feeds
translates languages detects fraudulent
Bank transactions
all driven by human
input in fact AI is poised to transform
everything we do and Canada is already
playing a vital role for me the biggest
risk is not adopting Ai and and
realizing it's its maximum
potential in 2017 the federal government
invested Millions into AI helping create
three world-renowned nonprofit
institutes they guide development in AI
research in Montreal Edmonton and here
in Toronto where dval pandia leads AI
engineering at the vector Institute he's
bet personally on Canada's future I
think it's very bright and uh if it
wasn't bright I wouldn't move to Canada
I guess in Ontario alone he says there
are 20 postsecondary programs with
training focused on AI providing
startups with a steady stream of new
workers last year we graduated more than
thousand Vector recognized Master
students and what is very impressive is
90% of the students they stay in Canada
in Ontario after they
graduate Professional Services firms
like deoe help companies find the next
big thing and it doesn't get bigger than
AI Jazz judge is a managing partner at
deoe in Toronto focusing on AI he
believes AI will be to the 21st century
what the steam engine was to the 18th
century electricity to the 19th century
and computers to the 20th
century you know what really happened in
all these major
developments if you look at it like
every major industry
changed societies changed Jazz gave us
an exclusive look at one of the ways AI
will change Healthcare so Mike let me
show you uh the demo this is your
digital teammate calling to follow up
with you after your heart failure
surgery regarding your post- discharge
medication
lowens this AI nurse was created in
partnership with the Ottawa Hospital to
check in with newly discharged patients
it doesn't always look like this its
skin tone even the dialect can be
altered to put a patient at ease as a
way to ensure posttop instructions are
being followed and if they're not they
will push back if the hospital's
requirements require that based on a
certain response the patient is being
stubborn yeah they could be bit
insistent in terms of saying heyy you
know what you haven't done what you were
supposed to so get on with it the goal
here isn't to replace human nurses is to
take some tasks off their already full
plates while lowering readmission rates
you know one of the concerns people have
though is oh progress means job losses
but it's not as simple as that right yes
this is a Hot Topic in terms of the
anxiety that some people have in terms
of the implications when it comes to the
work Workforce when it comes to AI the
way to think about it is not in a in a
way by which it will replace workers
rather it will reshape the workforce as
we move
forward even as the AI landscape grows
the big picture is already getting
smaller it's tucked away into the arms
of these ra Man glasses hey meta record
video Canadians are now buying products
based on a promise the rayb band camera
may work but the AI hasn't been turned
on yet in Canada the code is still being
tested are we getting ahead of ourselves
should we be releasing stuff before we
actually are able to fully test it this
is exactly my research area we shouldn't
be Isabelle Peterson is a professor at
Ontario Tech University she's been
studying wearable technology for over 20
years and even she is amazed at how fast
AI has become embedded in our daily
lives people went from never
experiencing AI themselves to being able
to use it on their phones to use it in
their you know on their laptops use it
at work use it at home and so we've gone
through this rapid process in a matter
of weeks that in in some other
Technologies took a 100 years to have an
AI assistant in our ear is
transformative and from ear to arm Hile
chowri wanted to see if AI could be as
big a disruptor in the world of glasses
as he intends to make it in the world of
Prosthetics you have to fight it great
grip from Canada team smart arm Hile
started Toronto Bas smart arm after
beating out 50,000 other inventors at a
competition sponsored by Microsoft
prosthetic arms he had learned were
either cheap but clunky or functional
but expensive so he set out to design
something affordable yet remarkable the
world's first bionic arm where AI uses
cameras to dictate
movement just like the way you know you
would look at um an object like that cup
in front of you for example and and grab
it you won't necessarily think about how
you'd wrap your fingers around it we've
tried to mimic that human sort of
tendency with AI so it's kind of like
hand ey coordination just done
digitally so the the hand will know just
to grab that's right which is hard for a
lot of people to wrap their head around
right smart arm isn't for sale yet
regulatory approvals are pending in the
mean time they're testing it on people
with a limb difference including former
NFL player Shae Griffin the first time
he actually put on Smart arm and and
interacted with it we were sitting at a
restaurant was picking up
repeatedly and and like picking up and
putting down a glass of water I think it
was at the time and and you know he take
a drink from it and he he put it down
he' pick it up again and like hand it to
me you witnessed somebody who had never
used their left hand before used their
left hand yeah uh essentially that'll
blow your
mind but as with everything AI related
there are questions the way that we
propose and strategize Technologies
don't rarely if ever turn out the
outcome is always different that's
really interesting because do we really
know which way AI is going to turn out
no we don't know that's scary absolutely
there are persistent concerns that AI is
moving much faster than the guardrails
being built for it the artificial
intelligence in data act won't come into
Force before
2025 Federal minister of innovation
Science and Industry franois Philip
Champa says they want to get it done
right
there's an acknowledgement we need to
deal with the concerns and the risks so
that we can realize the opportunities a
and in order to do that uh we need
framework we need guard Wills so we
build trust with
people but trust can be tricky until the
ACT becomes law there is a voluntary
code of conduct the key word there is
voluntary it is incumbent on
organizations and businesses themselves
to not only wait for things like
regulations and these types of
directives coming in but also go down
the path of really understanding how can
they self-regulate in the interim by
educating themselves and learning about
how this technology will really make a
difference to earn the trust of not only
your customers and your constituents
outside the organization but also your
Workforce inside the organization but
isn't that akin to the inmates running
the Asylum there's a danger there there
is a danger there but at the end of the
day you have to take a multi-pronged
approach to not be left behind while
everyone else is going to be doing this
anyways this much is true when it comes
to artificial intelligence Canada's
brightest minds are looking to the
Future AI is
empowering AI is human autonomy AI is a
transformative technology that is going
to make World a much better place and
help us solve some of the most pressing
challenges as a society you face right
now ai just is whatever we make it to
[Music]
be